Alrighty!
Calm down!
I'm so sorry!
We took so long!
God!
I'm sorry, everyone!
I know you guys waited for so long!
For 40 minutes, I'm so sorry!
Look, look, everybody, I know, I know.
There was a lot more work than I thought when I did this to
do this karaoke.
I was like I had so many ideas There was so many ideas in my
head It was crazy And then I like last minute I was like
wait I have more ideas And then guys come down Guys I know I
know you've been waiting for 40 minutes So I guess I haven't
even I've been like fucking standing there for 40 minutes
already And we haven't even started But then I had more
ideas And then I had to add some last minute my god i'm so
nervous i really am but we should we should really you know
we should guys camera close up camera come back come closer
how are you gonna see me up there you know how are you gonna
how are you gonna see me like this you know all right hello
everybody all right guys okay i'm so sorry uh you guys have
to wait that yeah i have to wait so long so sorry um i you
know i thought like uh don't worry i have everything i need
to do but then like suddenly my mom was like but like wait
there's more things i want to do though and then and then i
had like this some fucking crazy ideas that got some people
to help out for us too so like i'm okay by the way before
you before those who are new here who've never heard me sing
i need to tell you guys like i'm not a singer by no means am
i a singer i like basically make up for it with like with
making it like a show because although i can't sing at least
you'll have fun listening like not fun listening to my voice
but like with the visuals you know at least the visuals
would be nice like i like to say i'm i am a the type of
singer that you will not see me at karaoke because that's
how embarrassed i am uh to my uh at my own singing but i did
promise you guys a karaoke um as a charity uh reward so here
here i am i am i am very very very very nervous right now um
it's been a time since i guess you can say i sing with soul
you know you don't come to me to hear good singing you come
to me to i guess to laugh at my singing i guess anyway um
i'm gonna spoil the first song because um i have to wear a
little something for this song and also i need to i need
soundcheck guys to be here to check out the volume of this
as well so if soundcheck guy are you here are you here
soundcheck guy let me see is is soundcheck guy here we need
i need to be sure that the the sound is okay all right okay
we're gonna spoil we're gonna spoil the the first song chat
just because i need to know if you guys could hear it it
will be spoiled by the first song is this okay all right so
you sort of know what song this is now this is a this is a
don't keep your classic because this is the only this is
like one of the the five songs i'm like super confident in
all right let me up let me up put on something as well all
right all right it's pretty quiet let me bring it up all
right thank you soundcheck guy i'm glad we had soundcheck
guy here to help us out but anyway let's just let's put us
put our little costume on real quick and since we know what
song this is all right is this better is this better
like just like clicking edging with like with not even
seeing this it's just
i'm back now guys it's okay i'm back now that was so funny
because it was like what do you mean it's youtube because i
am my opus is still up and then like and then it crashed the
moment i like i typed that anyway let's do this again is the
song okay is it okay now
Is it okay now?
Is it okay?
That was awkward.
I like how I like I like how fucking It's still pretty
quiet.
Okay, I'll push it up.
Oh, it's because like, oh, it's because it reset itself.
It's because it reset itself when my OBS crashed.
All right, we're back.
Is it better now?
I like how we're just good here.
All right, this is it.
Finally.
Sorry, everybody.
Finally, we can fucking, we can finally sing.
All right, are you guys ready?
All right, we're back.
We're so back.
All right, here you go.
I'm gonna be a mighty king So enemies beware Oh, that's mean
I'm gonna be the main event Like no king was before up on
looking down I'm working on my right I just can't wait to be
king no one saying do this no one saying be there no one
saying stop that no one saying see here free to run around
all day It's definitely out.
Free to do it all my way.
Yeah, I'm the king.
I think it's time that you and I arrange the heart to heart.
Kings don't need advice from little hornbills for a start.
If this is where the monarchy is headed, call me out.
Out of service, out of the hour.
It's monarchy.
I wouldn't hide about.
This child is getting widely all the way.
That's me.
Oh, I just can't wait to be king.
Ba da, ba, ba, ba, ba.
Bam.
Hum.
Everybody look left.
Everybody look right.
Saturn's spotlight!
Not yet!
Yeah!
Let's hear it
again You'd see the finest king Oh, I just can't wait to be
king Oh, I just can't wait to be king Oh, I just can't wait
To be king
That's me
That's me That's me I'm the king
I went with the The safest choice For the first song Because
I know that This was a song I sang a lot as a little as a
little bird so like that is why I decided to go with like
the safest choice that's the first song because I know that
like um I say I know the song like really really really
really well because I've listened to the song on repeat ever
since I was little so I was like all right this is this is
gonna be the first song I'll sing then because I and I know
this it's a good it's a it's a good warm-up song because
it's like oh man every song i know this one is the one that
like i have like the most confident so yeah the very first
song um but yes if you guys i don't know never heard of
disney before the very first song i sang was i just can't
wait to be king from lion king where's my little there it is
this is my set list the very first song i sang i just can't
wait to be king yes there is gonna be a lot i'm gonna warn
you guys right now there's gonna be a lot of disney songs
because like uh disney songs is like the songs i'm most
confident in when it comes to singing uh so that's why i
decided it's majority disney uh majority of the stuff in
here is is disney so just just a little warning um give me a
sec i'm trying to grab my set list right now i think i'd
realize what's causing the the crashing a little bit and
it's because of uh i use uh i use caravan for like my
karaoke stuff and it's so fucking i guess it overloads
overloads my discord for some fucking reason which doesn't
make much sense because I'm like why does care fun overload
my discord?
So I'm just gonna grab my set list off of because I wrote my
set list off of discord.
So I'm gonna grab my set list and put it somewhere else so I
know where it is.
So I know which to go next.
Okay.
Let me let me make sure I can let me post this somewhere so
I can look at my set list whenever because like it's awkward
because like I was like forgot what to say next I'm so
nervous I'm so nervous right now and I'm forgetting things
at the moment oh okay I remember now guys this one this one
is also a classic that I like to uh let me all right you
guys might know what it is judging from what I'm wearing
soon very soon uh okay now you know what it is okay if you
guys can if you guys can recognize you know the first two
notes of that song, you might know what it is.
This is also a classic that...
I don't sing this as often, but I do like it very, very
much.
Okay.
Can I be?
I'm just doing what comes naturally.
How bad can I be?
I'm just following my destiny.
can I be?
I'm just doing what comes naturally.
How bad can I be?
How bad can I possibly be?
Something of principle in nature.
That almost every creature knows.
Call survival the fittest.
And chickens is how it goes.
The animal that wins is going to scratch and fight and claw
and fight and punch.
And the animal that does it, well the animal that does it,
well without someone
I'm just saying how bad can I be I'm just doing what comes
naturally how bad can I be I'm just following my destiny how
bad can I be I'm just doing what comes naturally how bad can
I be how bad can I possibly be as a principal in business
that everybody knows the sound Instead of people with the
money.
Make this everworld go around.
So I'm figuring my companies, I'm figuring my factory, I'm
figuring my corporate sign.
Everybody out there, you take care of yours and me.
I'll take care of mine, mine, mine, mine, mine.
Let me hear you say smogulent smoke.
Slippily stop.
Complain all you at once.
It's never, ever, ever gonna stop.
Come on!
How bad can I possibly be?
I'm just building economy.
How bad, I, I, I, can I be?
Just look at me paying this puppy.
How bad, I, I, I, I can't be?
Come on.
How bad, I, I, I, I, can't I be?
How bad can I possibly be?
Let's see.
All the customers are buying.
multiplying and a PR people are lying and the lawyers are
denying who cares if a few trees are dying this is all so
gratifying how bad that can this possibly
I'm a good person I don't know I think I'm a pretty good
person guys
anyway that was how bad can I be from Mr. Ed Helms himself
it's one of the one of the og tumblr boys out there what
capitalism does to a tomato um shout out to shout out to the
onesler the the og tumblr boy
let me take these off uh but it's how bad can i possibly be
of these songs I chose are like super in my vocal range
because or like I forced it to be in my vocal range because
I have a very very small vocal range so just letting you
guys know I'm like not even going to write numbers right now
I'm too lazy it's like one I just can't wait to be king two
how bad can I like not even two how bad can I be
but yes I hope I hope your ears are okay chat I know that
you know I'm not I'm not a singer so like I hope I hope
everybody's ears are okay so far and no one is uh no no one
is dying at the moment
Everybody's against me.
Oh my god.
I can't believe YouTube's dying.
They know.
They're like, Doki has a karaoke.
Doki has a karaoke today.
So like, we're gonna fuck with her.
They're like, we're gonna fuck with her.
They're trying to silence.
yeah they try to silence the tumbler sexy man agenda they
know obs knows i had a karaoke like youtube knows i had a
karaoke today they try to silence me anyway guys the next
song is also a classic um i have something special too for
the next song it's one of the reasons why this took a while
to prep for i'm gonna fumble with this because i didn't get
to I didn't get to practice this as much as I would like to
so like I'm gonna fumble I'm gonna fumble this song well to
be fair why I said I didn't practice as much I definitely
didn't practice a lot for this one but I really really want
to do it you're gonna realize what song is the moment I swap
the scenes you're gonna you're gonna realize what song this
is chat are you guys ready okay I don't know if you guys
could hear the video though so let me know you guys actually
hear the video do you guys actually hear this
you guys can okay okay i thought you guys can okay i need to
try to find all right there you are the dsc you guys can't
hear the song okay thank god good because that song's my
guide
that's good that's good because like that song my god for
for this okay so there's a reason why so long welcome to the
dragoon pta meeting um i have a i have a very very very
important news to tell i had like the reason why i summoned
all of you guys is that there is something very fucking
important that i need to address right now and um it's about
the children
i need you guys to know like this is this is very important
to me because this is about the kids And we need to do
something about it, okay?
Like, I summoned all of you here because I feel like we have
to, there is something really bad going around that's
affecting all our children and dragoons.
And that is why I am here today to summon all of you here
today for this very important dragoon PTA meeting.
As you guys see, I have a Doki Bird's plan of action.
I need to make sure I sync this video up correctly so it
works.
So give me a second.
You sync this video up.
Okay.
I need to make sure this video is synced up.
All right, let's see.
I hope this is synced up.
I'm not sure yet.
All right, we're going to try our best.
We're gonna try our best
Times have changed our kids are getting worse.
They won't obey their parents.
They just want to fight and curse Should we blame the
government?
Yeah, no, it's not it's not synced up guys.
Oh my god My OBS disconnected
Oh my god I can't believe it I saw my OVS disconnected And I
was like, bro
This is Everything's against me YouTube's actually trolling
me YouTube's actually trolling me today I can't believe it
YouTube I worked so hard on this YouTube Why today
I can't believe it YouTube's actually trolling me right now
Alright, here we go We'll try again We'll try again guys
This is good This time, YouTube please Let me finish the
song This cat in this fault This fucking cat in this fault
This is actually cat in this fault We'll try again Alright,
here we go
Times have changed Our kids are getting worse They won't
obey their parents, they just want to fart and curse.
Should we blame the government or blame society?
Or should we blame the Queen of the City?
No, blame Canada!
Blame Canada!
With all their beady little eyes and flopping heads and
full-full eyes!
Blame Canada!
We need to form a full assault!
It's heaven's fault!
Don't blame me for my son Dragoon!
He saw the darn cartoon and now he's off to join the clan!
And my boy Eric once had a crush picture on his shelf but
now I see him telling me to fuck myself well blame Canada
blame Canada it seems like everything's gone wrong since
kind of came along blame Canada blame Canada and I even a
real country anyway my son could have been a doctor or a
lawyer rich and true instead he'd burn up like a piggy on a
barbecue should we blame the matches should we blame the
fire or the
blame Canada with their other hockey holla boo and that
bitch don't keep her too blame Canada shame on Canada oh the
smut we must end the trash must smash the lack of fun must
all be a done we must blame them because of us before
someone thinks blame him oh
yes there you go
Thank you YouTube for letting me sing this song
YouTube Thank you for letting me get through this video So I
could So I could sing this song YouTube Huge shout out to
one of my editors Shad For doing this Literally they sent me
this like 10 minutes ago I had this idea like Well I had
several ideas I had this idea like in the morning and I was
like chat can you do this and then they're like I can try
and they like actually send this to me like 10 minutes ago
and a huge huge shout out to them
I had this setup thing made in advance and I was like don't
worry I won't be seeing blame Canada until later so like so
send it to me whenever it's done um so anyway for those who
don't know this was blame canada for uh from south park um
thank you for coming to my dragoon pta meaning uh i really
appreciate it and i just want to say like this is all
canada's fault that the karaoke has been like crashing this
much i'm really sorry i'm not sorry because this is canada's
fault so fuck you canada for crashing my pc for crashing my
youtube my obs and my pc Look, I worked so hard on this
karaoke Fucking Canada, man Anyway, it's time to go back to
the Alright, anyway, meetings adjourned Meetings adjourned
Back to the concert hall Well, back to the concert hall
Hey, I'm back, I'm back Anyway, guys That song was Blame
Canada uh from south park all right this next one um this
one i've always i've been wanting to sing for a very very
very very very very long time um i never ever had a chance
to sing this song because it's sort of it's not really
obscure it's more like internet stuff it's like um um it's
sort of like if you were on the internet when this come came
out like it was everywhere and like it was it's based off of
a it's like a a mini project starring a lot of like really
big celebrities back then but it was like a fucking passion
project and but like um it was like you know it didn't
really have like actual music rights or anything so i never
had a chance to really sing this song and this is like a
song i really really really wanted to sing for for a while
now anyway so i think um the best way to do this is if i is
if i got the spotlight on put this on and you'll realize why
you'll realize why i put the spotlight on for this song all
right
look at these people amazing how sheep will show up for the
slaughter No one's condemning you line up like lemons you
lead to the water Why can't they see what I see?
Why can't they hear the lies?
Maybe the fees to pricey for them to realize your disguise
is slipping I think you're slipping Now that your savior is
still as a graveyard beginning to fear me like caveman fear
funder i still have to wonder can you really hear me i bring
you pain the kind you can't suffer quietly fire up your
brain remind you inside your riding society is slipping yes
okay i downloaded the program maybe this will be better oh
my god guys i can't believe it are you guys ready round two
are you guys ready for round two are you guys ready oh my
god the stream slipped okay were you guys ready for round
two chat i'm ready for round two i'm ready for round two oh
my god i can't believe it it really is It really is.
All right, here we go.
Here we go again.
Stop it, Canada, please.
All right, let's see if this works.
Is the volume okay for this?
So I use the program right now.
I'm using it program this time.
All right, here we go.
Take two.
Anyway.
Look at these people.
Amazing how sheep will show up for the slaughter.
No one's condemning you line up like lemons You lead to the
water Why can't they see what I see Why can't they hear the
lies?
Maybe the fees to pricey for them to realize Your disguise
is slipping I think you're slipping Now that your savior is
still as a graveyard me like caveman fear thunder I still
have to wonder can you really hear me I bring pain the kind
you can't suffer quietly I up your brain remind you inside
your writing society is slipping everything's slipping away
so go ahead right away Spread the word, tell a friend, tell
them the tale.
Get a pet, do a bond.
Heroes are over with.
Look at him, not a word.
Hammer me, nail.
Then I win.
Then I get everything I have earned.
All the cash, all the fame, and so-so change.
Anarchy, better run.
It's Dr. Horrible's turn.
You people all have to learn.
This world is going to burn.
Burn.
Yeah, it's two R's.
H-O-R-R.
Yeah, right.
Burn.
now no sign of penny good i won't give any not not to have
sir sing it's gonna be bloody head up billy buddy there's no
time for mercy here goes no mercy
and then i get punched
Oh my god, maybe that was the way I just need it.
Alright guys, let's all expect a crash every two guys I'm
gonna say it now.
This is gonna be an archive.
This is a way too scum
I'm sorry, this is way too fucking scum.
This is gonna be an archive
We're crashing too much.
We're crashing way too much.
Maybe whatever I get a new PC We're going to we'll we'll
have another karaoke and bring back the...
It means you guys are lucky.
You've made it, though.
You've made it.
Anyway, for those who don't know what that song is, it is
Dr. Horrible's Sing-A-Long Blog.
It's called Slipping.
And Dr. Horrible's Sing-A-Long Blog was one of my favorite
animated series for, like...
It wasn't a series, no, it was like an anime movie.
It was like a small animated movie project that was like a
passion product they had like almost like no budget um but
like a lot of people were like really were like um it like
it became a cult hit basically it was a cult hit and uh and
uh it started neil patrick harris and then the other people
i don't remember the other sorry not animated sorry uh not
animate live action sorry i mean what do you mean live
action it was just a a it was just like a mini movie project
uh and um and it honestly i loved every song i love still
loved by the way i still love every fucking song that was in
that album uh and uh and there was like oh i think like
freeze ray honestly was oh yeah felicia day yeah felicia day
was in it freeze ray is one of my favorite freeze day freeze
ray is one of my favorite but I know I can't sing Freez Ray
because Freez Ray is mostly singing and I was like nope
it was uh it was I was like nope I can't sing Freez Ray so
like I'll just do slipping because slipping is also one of
my favorite songs and brand new day too almost every song in
there is like a is is almost like oh never mind not almost
all the songs in in Dr. Horrible Singalong Blog is so
fucking good and I'm so happy to do slipping is one of the
songs I've always wanted to sing so um so i'm glad i was
actually able to sing it here today for you guys i'm sorry
for the scuff i didn't realize fucking it never happened
before like all these crashes on karaoke day they knew
youtube and ob is new okay guys all right spoiler i'm
actually getting a new PC but like it's stuck in customs
it's been stuck in customs for two weeks now
Bro every day I wait and I was like which one who puts you
here and it's been stuck in customs for like Fucking Canada.
This is Canada's fault.
It's always Canada's fault.
God fucking damn it
I could have had my new PC, but now God damn it, Canada
Anyway, yes Thank you for listening to Okay, let me fucking
Where's my karaoke list?
Alright, here you go That was slipping I can't believe I
crashed Okay, we're just gonna expect crashes I don't want
to promise anything So like we're just I don't want to be
like Don't worry now because I don't know it might not not
be okay so I don't promise anything yet anyway let me bring
my piano over boom I can't play piano by the way but let me
bring my piano over I don't know how to play the piano but
like let me bring my piano over here um one of my favorites
still Okay, all these songs, okay, I should stop singing one
of my favorites Because technically all these songs are my
favorite All of them are my favorites So there's no
actually, like everything on here is one of my favorite
songs So I need to stop singing one of my favorites Alright,
I got my piano I'm seeing this version because I don't like
the original singer Okay, I like the original singer But
like I don't like, I prefer this version more so than the
original singer's version so you might know because i've
sang this before but i still love it because i feel like the
message is like really powerful you
can never know what it's like your blood like winter freeze
is just like ice and there's a cold lonely night that shines
from you you'll whine unlike the wreck you hide behind that
mask you use And did you think that girl couldn't ever win?
Well, look at me, I'm coming back again.
I got a taste of love in a simple way.
And you need to know I'm still standing.
You just fade away.
Well, don't you know I'm still standing better than I ever
did?
Looking like a true survivor, feeling like a little kid.
And I'm still standing after all this time.
Faking up the pieces of my life without you on my mind.
I'm still standing, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm still standing, yeah, yeah.
Once I never could hope to win, you staring down the roads
leaving me again.
The threats you made were meant to cut me down.
If our love was just a circus, you'd be a clown by now.
Don't you know I'm still standing better than I ever did
Looking like a true survivor Feeling like a little kid And
I'm still standing after all this time Taking out the pieces
of my life without you on my mind I'm still standing, yeah,
yeah Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Pio, pio, pio, pio, pio.
Pretend that my piano can also do guitar solos.
Pio, pio, pio, pio, pio, pio.
It's an electric piano.
Don't you know, I'm still standing better than I ever did?
Looking like a true survivor.
Feeling like a little kid.
After all this time Picking up the pieces of my life Without
you on my mind I'm still standing Yeah, yeah, yeah I'm still
standing Yeah, yeah, yeah I'm still standing Yeah, yeah,
yeah I'm still standing Yeah, yeah, yeah
All right, for those who don't know what that song was, that
was, uh, I'm still standing.
I don't know.
For those who still don't know what that is, who would have
known, that was, I'm still standing by Elton John, but also,
but I didn't sing Elton John's version because I like the
sing, the movie, movie sing version from Terran Eagerton,
um, who also played Elton John on his like biopic movie.
I honestly prefer his version so much more especially in the
sing one when he's a gorilla and it's been one of my
favorite songs like for a very long time so I am very happy
to be able to sing this anyway let me chuck this piano out
thank you thank you piano I really appreciate it piano for
uh uh for doing that okay i'm still standing i really
appreciate the piano that could totally play chat the piano
that i'm i'm deaf i definitely played uh uh in front of all
of you guys all right next song next song okay oh okay uh
this one is this one's gonna be fun this one's gonna be fun
might enjoy this but like i need to time it time time the
video this one also has a video chat so you guys might enjoy
this let me let me put this let me find the song real quick
uh i need to make sure it's the right version i need to time
this time this video as well but we're gonna move guys we're
gonna um we're gonna move to another another setup real fast
guys all right all the concert hall out the concert hall
everybody we're gonna go somewhere all right are you guys
already i know there's so many of you guys out out we're
gonna move to another venue real quick but we'll come back
we'll come back to this venue i just need you guys to all
move out right now all right three two one boom all right
okay so i need to make sure that uh all right here i need to
make sure i timed this correctly
all right so here's our new venue don't worry there is a
reason why we're in this venue because the next song that
we're seeing requires a big bigger venue like i need all
this open space uh i i really need all this open space for
for this particular venue and you're gonna realize when
we're here but i need to make sure the video is timed
correctly so that is like the biggest So let me, let me make
sure this, this video is timed perfectly.
Hey.
All right, here you go.
This should be it.
All right, I hope this is correct.
I, I hope, I hope that I timed it correctly.
So we're gonna see.
We're gonna, we're gonna.
All right, here we go.
You're gonna realize what this song is.
The moment we play.
Huh?
Well, you Baba had them 40.
These shattered highs and a thousand tails.
But Master, you in luck, cause of your sleeves.
You got a brand of magic never fails.
You got some power in your corner now.
Some heavy ammunition in your camp.
You got some punch, possess, yaku, and how.
See how you got yours, rub, la, la.
And I'll say, Mr. Aladdin, sir, what will your pleasure be?
Can I take your order, jolt it down?
You ain't never had a friend like me.
Life is your restaurant, and I'm your maider, Dee.
Come on, whisper what it is you want.
You ain't never had a friend like me.
Prider sells on service.
You're the boss, the king, the shah.
Say what you wish, it's yours trudish.
Well, a little more black la-ba.
Pass some of column A, try all of column B.
I'm in the mood to help you dig.
had a friend like me.
Nah, nah, nah, nah, no, no.
Mah, nah, nah.
Nah, nah.
Can your friends do this?
Can your friends do that?
Do your friends pull this?
On their little hat.
Can your friends go poop?
Well, look at here.
Can your friends go abracadabra?
Let it rip and then make that sucker disappear!
So interested Sarah's slack job buddy guide!
I'm here to answer all your midday prayers!
You got me bona fide, certified!
You got Gina for your shard of affairs!
I got a powerful urge to help you out!
So what you wish you ever really want to know!
You got a list that's three miles long, no doubt!
Well, I got to disrupt like so and oh!
Mr. Al- Mr. have a wish or two or three!
I'm on the job, you big nabob!
You ain't never had a friend, never had a friend, You ain't
never had a friend.
Never had a friend.
You ain't never had a friend like me.
Ha ha ha.
Yes.
That was also by...
shad huge shout out to shad for this amazing video edit um i
gave him some of the ideas to do you know i used to do this
all by myself manually but then i was like why am i doing
this all by myself manually when i can like actually have
like you know when it can just play automatically for me
instead of me pressing on these buttons
But yes, huge shout out.
For those who don't know, it's never, sorry, never a friend
like me from Aladdin, the 1992 version with Robin Williams.
Because I'm sorry, Will Smith, but you can never live up to
Robin Williams version, the original genie.
So this was the original Robin Williams version of Friend
Like Me.
It's also one of my favorite songs as well.
I don't like the live-action movie songs There's some of
them that's actually pretty decent But then there's so The
majority of them is pretty fucking shit
Anyway guys We're still just staying in this venue chat So
don't worry You don't have to move chat We're all still in
this venue So So do not worry chat You don't have to move
We're all gonna be here
um anyway let me grab all right the next song i feel like
you sort of know what the next song is by a few things i'm
gonna put up my screen real quick uh let me get rid of
friend like me um whoa we're underwater now we're gonna swim
oh my god are those fishes oh my god there's fishes now
I hope that I hope that I mean it's sadly going to be
unarchived because it was so scuff in the beginning I was
crashing non-stop I was crashing non-stop so sadly this is
going to be archived guys don't worry um dragoons can not
breathe underwater but like don't worry at least you get to
watch this before you drown so uh
uh all right so are you guys ready for this song uh i'm
gonna go in i didn't practice this song at all and to be
fair i'm going to go in like i'm gonna go in from all the
practice i've done as a little kid and i hope that i didn't
practice the song at all recently and i'm just hoping that
my fucking instinct is gonna kick in and remember this song
but yes has the volume been okay so far I hope it's not
instrumentals have not been too loud I hope the
instrumentals have been okay and not too loud chat
alright good okay here we go yay wait before we start I need
to hydrate I realize I haven't been really hydrating hmm
okay let me hydrate real whoa whoops at least that bottle of
water is empty hydrate guys all right here we go here we go
all right i'm gonna hope that muscle memory kicks in here i
added this last minute because i was like i love this song
the seed weed is always green now and somebody else is like
you dream about going there but that is a big mistake just
look at the world around you right here on the ocean floor
such wonderful things surround you what more is you looking
for under the sea under the sea darling it's better
downwards wet to take it from me up on the shore they work
all day out in the sun to slave away while we devoting full
time to floating under the sea.
Down here all the fish is happy as all through the waves
they roll.
The fish on the land ain't happy.
They sad cause they're in their bowl.
But fish in the bowl is lucky.
They in for a worse fate.
One day when the boss gets hungry, guess who's coming on
that play?
Uh-oh, under the sea.
Under the sea, nobody beat us, fry us and eat us in
fricassee.
We what the land folks loves to cook, under the sea we off
the hook.
We got no troubles, life is the bubbles.
Under the sea, under the sea, since life is sweet here, we
got the beat here, naturally.
Even the surgeon and the rave, they get the urge to start to
play.
You've got to hear it under the sea.
The newt play the flute, the carp play the harp, the place
play the bass and they sounding sharp.
The bass play the brass and the chub play the tub.
The fluke is the duke of soul.
The right he can play, the lings on the string.
The trout rocking out, the blackfish he sings.
The smell and the sprite, they know where it's at.
And oh, that blowfish blow!
I hope you're not drowning in water now, dragons, Water!
Yeah!
Under the sea!
When the sardine begin to begin, this music to me!
What do they say?
A lot of sand!
We got a hot crustacean fan!
Each little clam here know how to jam here under the sea!
Each little slug here, caught in a rug here, under the sea.
Each little snail here, do you know how to wail here?
That's why it's hot here, under the water.
Yeah, we're lucky, down in the muck here, under the sea.
Woo!
Huge shout out to Little Doki for fucking singing the song
almost every day when she was a kid.
Well, not that.
Huge shout out to Little Doki I didn't practice this song at
all Today So like huge shout out to Little Doki For like
Still fucking clutching it for me Because I sang this song a
lot
I was just like Oh my god Okay I'm gonna sing this I don't
know how I'm gonna do live But like It can't be that bad
Alright Alright all right guys we're gonna move venues uh
we're gonna move venues real quick but we're not gonna go
back to the main venue yet chat so uh give me a sec guys
we're gonna be moving to another venue everybody leave the
ocean leave leave the ocean chat leave we're gonna swim back
up now swim back up dragons swim back up we need a we need
to go out of the ocean to another venue what you mean by
that well I'm down dragons I've turned into a TV funniest
shit ever oh my god funniest fucking shit ever guys all
right I'm gonna go straight in I practice to sound like
twice i think this is the right one right yeah this is the
right one this was a triumph i'm making a note here huge
success it's hard to overstate my satisfaction aperture
science We do what we must because we can For the good of
all of us Except the ones who are dead But there's no sense
crying over every mistake You just keep on trying till you
run out of cake And the science gets done And you make a
neat gun For the people who are still alive
I swear I'm being so sincere right now.
Even though you broke my heart and killed me.
I swear I'm not angry.
And tore me to pieces.
And threw every piece into a fire.
As they burned it hurt because I was so happy for you.
of data make a beautiful line and we're out of beta we're
releasing on time so I'm glad I got burned think of all the
things we've learned we're the people who are still alive
and there's people still alive guys don't worry go ahead and
leave me I think I prefer to stay inside Maybe you'll find
someone else to help you.
Maybe Black Mesa.
That was a joke.
Ha ha, fat chance.
Anyway, this cake is great.
It's so delicious and moist.
Look at me still talking when there's science to do.
When I look out there, it makes me glad I'm not here.
There is research to be done on the people who are still
alive.
And believe me, I am still alive.
I'm doing science and I'm still alive.
I feel fantastic.
And I'm still alive.
While you're dying, I'll be still alive.
And when you're dead, I'll be still alive.
Still alive.
Because I'm virtual.
I don't know if you know that.
Just so you guys know.
I'm just, I'm virtual.
And that's why I'm still be alive.
Anyway, you don't get the cake.
No, my immersion!
Donkey!
I'm jamming out!
no kick for you guys sorry because i'm the one that's still
alive all right guys i'm gonna like undownload myself from
the tv now and for those who don't know that song was still
alive from portal um uh honestly uh i remember like
listening to that song on repeat when i was like a little
little dokey so i was like you know what let's do it also
like i wanted to sing this for a while too but like
obviously like still alive has like a weird song like when
it comes to When it comes to like berms and stuff.
Yes, I downloaded a cake into the TV.
So it's now mine.
So I'm glad I'm able to actually sing this song.
It was a little scuffed.
I mean, to be fair, this entire karaoke was a little
scuffed.
But it's not about how well I sing.
It's about how good it looks.
It's all about the visuals.
Not about how I sing.
Just look at how pretty everything looks.
All right, time to go back to the venue, guys.
Move along.
Back to the concert hall.
Back to the concert hall, everybody.
All right, we're back here.
I don't think I'm going to update the list.
I'm getting lazier, so we're going to...
I'm getting a little lazier, so I'm just going to get rid of
the list right now.
Anyway, guys, anyway, this one is a classic, too.
It's Christmas now.
Oh my god.
Do you know at this point with global warming, it might as
well be?
You know, it might as well be like...
It might as well...
It might as well still be snowing.
Okay, let me...
Let me second pull this.
I don't know if it's actually in care fun.
So I'm going to see if this is...
I know I sang this before.
So I'm like, is this...
Oh, it is!
Wait.
is that is that the right one let me double check this is
the right one hey let me double check this I need to make
sure this is one of my favorite okay all of them are my
favorites yeah okay it is nice I love this okay alright
alright you guys ready here we go oh I spoiled it
I'm Mrs. White Christmas, I'm Mrs. Snow.
I'm Mrs. Icycle, I'm Mrs. Tenbelow.
Friends call me Snow Miser, whatever I touch.
Turns to snow in my clutch.
Oh, I'm too much.
Oh, it's so cold.
That's me!
That's right!
He's Mr. Isaac, but he's Mr. Sambalow.
Friends call me Snow Miser.
Whatever I touch, turns the snow in my clutch.
Oh, I'm too much.
I never want to know a day that's over 40 degrees.
I'd rather have it 30, 20, then five, then let it freeze.
Oh, brr.
I'm Mrs. White Christmas I'm Mrs. Snow, that's right!
I'm Mrs. Ice-sickle I'm Mrs. Tambolo Friends call me Snow
Miser, whatever I touch Turns to snow in my clutch Too much.
Ah, too much.
Oh yeah, I...
this song okay like i have like a favorite cover version of
this song and it's from like it's like a female version of
this and like she's so good like she sounds like spinel from
like that the the the that's even universe movie she sounds
just like her and like she did like a female version cover
of uh snow miser and that song's been stuck in my head ever
since um huge shout out to her though because she is
actually so fucking talented and like she honestly like
inspired like not inspire me but like she actually like made
me uh made me like really like this song in general because
of the the english cover of i think if you look up female
cover uh snow mazer uh you might be able to find it like it
it's sort of it has like uh like i i'm basically sort of
emulating her voice when i sing this yeah like when you hear
the cover you're like oh yeah she's definitely trying to
like emulate her voice yes this is uh this one was uh snow
miser from something something the year of santa claus uh
the original version i don't like it as much to be fair uh i
don't really like Heat miser song.
Heat miser is like way too fucking slow for me.
Um so but like Snow miser is like I don't I don't know I I
never like thought much about the Snow miser song until like
I heard the female cover of it and it was just so um um that
is like that's why like it's I like remember it so well um
because like the female cover was just so good.
Anyway it's snowy stopped everything no more snow
everything's gone now snow has melted now for reals all
right what's the next song snow my zero is too much oh here
you go okay uh let's see let me put on an outfit real fast
all right Oh So I sort of like spoiled you guys a bit with
this song I spoiled it earlier And you see that put back a
Certain goggles
I put back like a certain goggles Because there's a reason
why And you'll know why soon We'll just go straight in we're
gonna go straight in I should use the app instead of the
actual fucking web program I think like that was the mistake
I made I was the mistake I've made for all the crashes yeah
I might okay warning I'm gonna fumble this a lot I did I
only practice a little bit for this I'm gonna try I'm gonna
try my best disappear as a moral dilemma because at first it
was weird though i swore to eliminate the worst of the
plague that devour where humanity it's true i was vague on
the house so how can it be that you have shown me the light
it's a brand new day and the sun is high all the birds are
saying that you're gonna die how i hesitate and now i wonder
why it's a brand new day All the times that you beat me, a
conscious I'll forgive.
All the crimes that are complete, and it's honestly I'll
live.
Mr. Cool, Mr. Right, Mr. Know-It-All is through.
Now my future is so bright, and I owe it all to you who
showed me the light.
It's a brand new day.
I got no remorse.
Now the water's rising, but I know the course.
I'm gonna shock the world, gonna show bad horse.
It's a brand new day.
And Penny will see me, the evil in me.
not a dork not a failure and she may cry but her tears will
dry when I hand her the keys to a shiny new Australia it's a
brand new day yeah the Sun is high all the angels sing
because you're gonna die go ahead and laugh yeah I'm a funny
guy It's a brand new day Yeah, it's also Dr. Horrible So the
reason why I have a city behind me Is that like It's called
Brand New Day Also from Dr. Horrible's Sing Along blog And
then The reason why I have a city behind me Is that in the
music video He's in like in his dreams feet tall and he
starts like fucking being Godzilla and like crushing all the
city the city around him so that this is me pretend I'm like
like a hundred feet tall right now stomping through the city
and like pushing everything down just like the music video
yeah I'm like a Kaiju right now this is Kaiju Doki at the
mall like
But but that is like the ending of the fucking song.
That's why That's why there's a city by me if you're a dr.
Horrible sing-along blog fellow fan you would you would you
would recognize the the reference
Majority of visual are just like you know things that you
can like you recognize you're like oh my god I was in the
video, you know, you're like oh my god, I know this this was
in the video okay And the next song let me hydrate real fast
you can tell I haven't sang in a long time just because I'm
so bad and uh um you can tell that uh I'm not very good at
singing because I'm compensating right now
um all right I'm fumbling a lot because I'm super nervous
and like when I was crashing a lot I'm like the crashes
actually uh fuck with my groove it actually messed my groove
up all right anyway um we're gonna move venue and start
kicking you guys out again uh i'm gonna i'm gonna kick you
guys out again uh because we're gonna be moving to a new
venue uh you might recognize this background uh this place
that i'm bringing you to uh all right give me a sec whoa
okay you guys recognize that
another venue change chat another um another another venue
change uh you guys might recognize this
okay i hope that i timed this okay like
all right let's try this okay this is um we all thought the
other stuff was scuffed this might be very scuffed okay i
just don't know if i can time this correctly okay welcome to
the internet have a look around anything that brain of yours
can think of can be found oh wait you guys can't hear it
already scuffed i just realized you can't even hear it sorry
we'll try again soon i almost acapella did I don't know.
Oh no.
Instrumentals are supposed to hide my flaws.
I realized last minute.
I almost acapellad.
All right, here you go.
Welcome to the internet.
Have a look around.
Anything that brain of yours can think of can be found.
We've got mountains of content.
Some better, some worse.
If none of it's of interest to you, you'd be the first.
internet come and take a seat would you like to see the news
or any famous women's feet there's no need to panic this
isn't a test just nod a shake your head and we'll do the
rest welcome to the internet what would you prefer would you
like to fight for civil rights or tweet a racial slur be
happy be horny be bursting with rage we've got a million
different ways to engage Welcome to the internet, put your
cares aside.
Here's a tip for straining pasta, here's a nine-year-old who
died.
We've got movies and doctors and fantasy sports.
And a bunch of colored pencil drawings of all the different
characters in, like, I don't know, fucking each other.
Welcome to the internet.
Hold on to your socks, because a random guy just kindly sent
you photos of his cock.
They are grainy and off-putting, he just sent you more.
Don't ask surprise, you know you like it, you whore.
See a man beheaded, get offended, see a string.
Pictures of your children tell us every thought you think
Shout a rumor by a broom source and a death threat to a
boomer Or DM a girl and groomer, do a zoom or find a tumor
in Here's a healthy breakfast option, you should kill your
mom Here's why women never fuck you, here's how you can
build a bomb Which power ranger are you?
Take this quirky quiz, Obama sent the immigrant kids to
vaccinate your kids Look at I interest you in everything all
of the time A little bit of everything all of the time
Anything and everything all of the time Could I interest you
in everything all of the time?
A little bit of everything all of the time Apathy is a
tragedy and boredom is a crime Anything and everything all
of the time
Ah, I love Bo Barham You know, it wasn't always like this I
used to play Neon Pets.
Not very long ago.
Just before your time.
Right before the towers fell.
Circa 99.
This was catalogs.
Travel blogs.
Chat room or two.
Set our sights.
Spend our nights.
for you yeah you unshakable you mommy let you use her iPad
you were barely too man it did all the things we designed it
to do look at you Look at you You Unstoppable Watchable Your
time is now Your insides out Honey, how you grew And if we
stick together Who knows what we'll do It was always the
plan to put that world in your hand
could I interest you in everything all of the time a bit of
everything all of the time apathy is a tragedy And boredom
is a crime Anything and everything all of the time Could I
interest you in everything all of the time?
A little bit of everything all of the time Apathy is a
tragedy and boredom is a crime Anything and everything and
anything and everything and everything And all of the time
Oh my god I didn't realize how fast oh wait how fast the the
beginning was holy i forgot how fast oh how fast the
beginning was i'm stumbling my my my lips are stumbling
uh but yes welcome to the internet from from bo berham um
i've always like hesitated to sing this song because bo
berham was like you know was like you know very very you
know there's a lot in there in that song but i was like you
know what you know what i'm gonna sing it i was like fuck it
i'm gonna i'm gonna fucking sing the song i don't i don't
care anymore i want to i want i want i remember like when it
first came out i was like geez i like had that song on
repeat and it was like um it was honestly it's so good it's
such a It's such a really good song.
Even though, even though like, you know, the lyrics in there
is a little, whoa.
The lyrics is like, whoa.
But like, it's, it's, you know, you can't deny.
It's a fucking earworm.
Like it's stuck, it gets stuck in your head.
And the parodies are also really, really, really fucking
good.
Anyway, I am kicking guys out of this room.
This is actually somebody's room that broke in.
So I'm going to kick you guys out because we got a, uh we
don't live here we gotta go back to the concert hall guys we
gotta we gotta go back so back to the concert hall we go
you're back here again i know it's it's a lot of work like
moving you guys back and forth a lot but here we are again
here we are all right so this one this one um um we're just
gonna like listen to honestly it's just gonna be Like, you
didn't hear the backing vocals because I thought it was
really funny if I sang the song.
But there's no actual, there's no actual, like, how do I
say, there's no actual, like, karaoke of it.
So we're just gonna sing it because I thought it was really
funny.
I thought it was really good.
So I was like, you know, we're gonna sing it without the,
without the, there's no karaoke.
So like, I thought it would be a good time to sing this.
Oh, okay, sorry, you guys heard it.
You're like, all right, let me see.
I'm going to find the lyrics version so I know how to sing
it.
Okay, here we go.
All right, so the reason why is because I thought this song
really fits me really well.
To be fair, this is like the most skeptical wait this is
actually sort of like the rest after that i haven't no other
songs after this i'll just like are not like prepared
there's no like sets for anything for it but i just went
after this song actually no after the welcome to the
internet songs after that there's actual no no like sets or
props for the songs after that but so like you could take
welcome to the internet as like the finale but we're still
going on we're gonna still go on
um okay let me double check this
okay okay all right here you go all right guys ready guys
ready chat all right here we go if i fumble at least like
you know the actual singers will sing the song for me
okay here here we go
We're doing a sequel We're back by popular demand Come on
everybody Strike up a band We're doing a sequel That's what
we do in V-Tubing And everybody knows the sequels Never
quite as good Friends this is it Do it all again Until the
credits roll, we got another goal to show that we can do it
all again!
Doing a sequel.
There's no need to disguise.
Really?
We're doing a sequel.
The Dragoons once more.
Now they wait for Tom Hanks to make Toy Story 4.
It was the end, but no, my friends, this is when we do, do
it all.
all again let's give it a shot oh I need now is a half
decent plot oh my god getting Dokibert back together oh my
god her motto's her skins is four years old but we're doing
it
huh on a world tour.
Tocky goes on a world tour!
My friends, this is it, we get to do it all again!
We got another goal to show that we can do it all again!
The Tocky World Tour!
But it's again!
It's a Tocky again!
It's the Tocky!
Again!
Okay, I just stopped there.
This is like, I really wanted to sing this song.
Even though I had no karaoke, I really wanted to sing.
It just ends like that.
The abrupt cut.
I really wanted to sing because I was like, this is so, this
feels so me.
The Doki World Tour.
It just, it actually just stops there.
I was like, wait, what?
I was so surprised.
I thought there'd be more.
But I guess this was the movie version.
I got the movie version, by the way.
Um, I was like, all right, this must be the right video, I
think, because it's like, but there's actually a four minute
video, but I was like, you know what, the short version is
good enough.
The short version is, is good enough for us.
Uh, but it's, we're doing a sequel God this relates to me.
This relates to me so hard.
So I was like we're gonna we're gonna do it all again guys
we're gonna do it all again.
All right okay let me pull up uh I wrote like some other
songs that I wanted to do like as a bonus for all you guys
but I need like find it I need to find I need to find my
list.
Okay um okay let's see uh let's see let's see all right so i
have like three bonus songs i have three bonus songs for you
guys i don't have a set for this but uh i will i'm willing
to do it for you guys uh let's see uh all right here you go
i've always liked this song i mean i love all the songs
I love all of them.
That's the secret.
All right, here we go.
Here we go.
This one.
Nope.
Good thing you guys didn't hear that.
All right, here we go.
All right.
Okay.
Guys, ready?
Alright.
So, the only way to get what you want is to become a human
yourself.
My dear, sweet child.
That's what I do.
It's what I live for.
To help unfortunate dragoons like yourself.
Poor souls with no one else to turn.
too.
I admit that in the past I've been a nasty they weren't
kidding when they called me well a witch.
But you'll find that nowadays I mended all my ways.
Repent to seem the light and made a switch.
True?
Yes.
And I fortunately know a little magic.
It's a talent that I've always had possessed.
And dear lady please don't laugh.
I use it on behalf of the miserable lonely and depressed
pathetic poor unfortunate souls in pain and nude this one's
lying to be thinner that one wants to get the girl and do I
help them yes indeed those poor unfortunate souls so sad so
true they come flocking to my cauldron crying spells are so
pleased and I help them yes I do let's happen once or twice.
Someone couldn't pay the price.
And I'm afraid I had to rake and cross the coals.
Yes, I've had beyond complaint.
But on the whole, I've been a saint to those poor
unfortunate souls.
Have we got a deal, Dragons?
If you become human, I'll never be with my father and
sisters again.
But you'll have you.
You're Doki!
Life's full of tough choices, isn't it?
Oh.
And there is one more thing.
Hmm.
We haven't discussed the subject of payment.
I'm not asking much.
Just a token, really?
An Akasupa?
What I want from you is your voice.
You'll have your looks?
beak and don't underestimate the importance of body language
the men out there don't like a lot of blabber they think a
girl who gossips as a boy yes I'm Lannis Pritch preferred
for ladies not to say a word and after all dear what is idle
Pratt for come on they're not that impressed with
conversation true gentlemen avoid it when they can but they
don't ensue in fun on a lady who's withdrawn is she who
holds her tongue who gets a man.
Come on, you poor and fortunate soul.
Go ahead.
Make your choice.
I'm a very busy woman.
I haven't got all day.
It won't cost much.
Just your voice.
You poor and fortunate soul.
It's sad.
But true.
If you want to cross the bridge, my sweet, you've got to pay
the toll.
Take a gulp and take a breath and go ahead and sign the
scroll.
Floss them, Jessam.
Now I've got it, boys.
The boss is on a roll.
This poor, unfortunate soul!
Beluga, Saruga, come winds of the Caspian Seas.
Larissa glass, this is Latin, I cannot say la voce to me.
Now super chat.
Guess more!
Keep super chatting!
Thank you.
That is the longest fucking outro.
I forgot.
Thank you for all the super chats, everybody.
Oh my god, did I got Jesus Christ?
Thank you, Jesus, for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That was funny.
I forgot how long the outro was for this fucking song.
oh there you go alright do we end it with another do we do
we do another Disney song you know I'll do an encore of a
song we did before for the ending but let me let me do let's
see we'll do this this oh my gosh so that's what fell I was
like what the fuck fell and it was my it was my it was my
stream deck
alright oh my god free super chat David, thank you for the
Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
All right.
You know, let me...
All right, we'll do this one.
I actually do have props for this.
So, give me a sec.
Let me...
Actually, I don't.
I don't know where it is.
I didn't prepare this prop because this was a bonus song.
But this is another Disney song.
I'll sing another Disney song for all you guys.
And it will end it with a encore of a song I did before.
I forgot to hydrate.
You might recognize this because it's on my channel.
It's also one of the easiest Disney songs out there, so
there's no way I can fuck it up, right?
Bam.
Hello.
Look for the bare necessities, the simple bare necessities.
Forget about your worries and your strife.
That's right.
I mean the bare necessities, old mother nature's recipes
that bring the bare necessities of life.
Wherever I wonder, wherever I roam, I couldn't be fonder of
my big home.
The bees are buzzing in the trees and make some honey just
for me.
under the rocks and plants and take a glance at the fancy
ants and maybe try a few.
The bare necessities of life will come to you.
They'll come to you.
Look for the bare necessities, the simple bare necessities.
Forget about your worries and your strife.
That's right!
I mean the bare necessities.
at ease with just the bare necessities of life.
Now, when you pick a paw paw, or a prickly pear, and you
prick a raw paw, well, next time, beware, don't pick that
prickly pear by the paw, when you pick a pear, try to use
the claw, but you don't need to use the claw when you pick a
pair of the big paw paw, have by giving you a clue.
Hmm?
You understand?
The bare necessities of life will come to you.
They'll come to you.
Alright.
Pretend I have a trumpet solo.
I have a trumpet right now.
Oh, wait.
I know.
My piano trumpet.
Pretend my piano's playing the trumpet.
It's like those electric pianos.
Oh my god, now I'm doing margaritas on my electric piano.
Oh my god.
Oh,
look at my fingers go on the piano.
Oh.
How does she do it on the electric piano?
Chucked it off.
Ah, man, that was really living.
So just try and relax.
Yeah, cool it.
Fall apart in my backyard.
Because let me tell you something, little britches.
You act like that bees act.
Uh, uh, uh, you're working too hard.
And don't spend your time looking around for something you
want that can't be found.
When you find out you can live without it and go along.
Not thinking about it.
I'll tell you something true.
The bare necessities of life will come to you.
They'll come to you.
Look for the fair necessities, the simple fair necessities.
Forget about your worries and your strife.
Damn right, I mean the fair necessities.
That's why a bear can rest at ease with just the bare
necessities of life.
With just the bare necessities of life.
Yeah, man!
Did you know this is the easiest Disney song out there in
the world?
There's no way I could fuck it up.
It's literally the one that easiest Disney songs out there.
Praise for bare necessities.
Yeah, it's literally the easiest one.
Out of all the Disney songs out there, if you look it up,
the bare necessities is the easiest because it has like a
very small vocal range.
like it's like the vocals for it is like super simple and
and thank god because like i'm not like a gifted singer
anyway last song chat we made it to the we're doing an
encore um of a song that i've done before and i think you
guys want me to do this again i'm pretty sure
so so we'll do the last the very last song all right i'm
gonna make sure i time this this correctly because like
that's the worst part is just timing all right let me make
sure i time this correctly all right all right we're gonna
move the venue guys this is the last song we're gonna do an
encore of a song we've done before uh but we're gonna move
venues you guys will you guys love this place um anyway i'm
gonna start up the the dragon pta meeting again guys guys
okay i feel like i have to reiterate about regarding um this
issue that we have um that has cursed this fucking stream in
the beginning um so new meeting new dragoon pta meaning i
have a new new dragoon pta meeting chat
all right all right these are some issues that we have have
to redo this meeting because like um nothing has really been
fixed but anyway let's go
i need i need to blame something okay i forgot sorry i need
to restart this fucking canada okay give me a sec let me
restart guys new dragon pta meaning guys new dragon pta
meaning here we go now i'm ready times have changed our kids
are getting worse they won't obey their parents, they just
want to fight and curse.
Should we blame the government or blame society?
No!
Blame Canada!
With all their beady little eyes and flapping heads so full
of lies!
Blame Canada!
We need a form of full assault!
It's Canada's fault!
Don't blame me for my son Dragoon
and my picture on his shelf!
Now as DM tells me to fuck myself!
Well, blame Canada!
Blame Canada!
Oh wait, this is Alkapella.
It's like how I came along.
Blame Canada!
They're not even a real country anyway.
My son could've been a doctor or a lawyer rich and true.
Instead he burned up like a piggy on a barbecue.
This is Canada's fault.
Heck no!
Blame Canada!
Well, they're Hockey Halliboo and that bitch Doki Birdie to
blame Canada.
Shame on Canada.
The sun who is head, the trash must smash.
Laughter and fun must all be undone.
We must blame them.
They cause a fuss.
For someone, things are blaming us.
Fucking Canada's fault.
Of course Canada ruined my encore.
I did Acapella.
Fucking God fucking damn it, Canada.
Canada made me do an Acapella.
We're doing this again.
I refuse to do this whole song in Acapella Encore of an
encore Fucking Canada man It's okay Guys this is gonna be an
archive by the way This is way too scuffed Wait this way too
scuffed Wait we're unarchiving We're unarchiving this Don't
worry, round two
their pta meaning times have changed our kids are getting
worse they won't obey their parents they just want to fight
and curse should we blame the government or blame society or
should we blame no of course not no blame Canada blame
Canada with all their beady little eyes and flapping heads
so full of lies blame Canada blame Canada I mean the form of
full of solid cats fault they ruined my stream bro they
ruined my stream saw the dark cartoon now he's off to join
the clan and my boy dragon once had a picture on his shelf
but now I see him tells me to fuck myself blame Canada blame
Canada it seems that everything's gone wrong since Canada
came along blame Canada they're not even a real country
anyway my son could have been the doctor or a lawyer rich
and true and said he'd burn up like a piggy on a barbecue
No!
Blame Canada!
They ruined my stream!
They're karaoke!
Blame Canada!
Blame my Canada!
Oh, the smoke was cut, the trash was smashed, the laughter
and fun must all be done.
We must blame them and cause a fuss before someone thinks of
blaming us!
Alright, I'm done.
I'm done blaming Canada.
Sorry, this is like four times I sang this song.
like I fucking feel it
God fucking damn it Canada I sang the song four times that's
how pissed off I am
I can't believe I sang this acapella I had to I had to tell
the world of how much Canada has forsaken me and my
Canadian, fucking Canadian customs and Canadian ISP and
fucking Canada
Anyway, back to the concert hall Where is my PC?
Alright, Riverbob.
Where is my PC?
Alright, anyway.
way um i hope you guys enjoyed um okay okay okay guys the
reason why i don't want to archive this is because it was so
fucking scuffed from the beginning um when i could have just
like honestly used the program care fun program instead of
like the um instead of like the web version and it was the
word version that was causing all my crashes and the moment
i swapped um the moment i i swapped to to to like the the
actual um the the program is stopped crashing and i'm like
no i wish i'd done that in the beginning and then we would
have been scutted we would have been crashing
no i'm a coward though i'm a coward and i'm a coward okay
guys okay okay guys okay convince me to archive this okay
all right thanks for scuff and mix it ah i'm just
embarrassed i'm such a perfectionist because i worked so
hard i was so hard planning all of this so i was like that's
why i was like so sad i planned like i worked so hard trying
to plan all of this and doing all the assets and everything
so i was like so embarrassed when i started crashing
are you guys sharing are you guys sharing should archive
this are you guys sharing okay okay okay i'll i'll for you
guys drag goods i'm so embarrassed but for you guys i'll
archive i'll keep this archive i'll keep it like i'm so
embarrassed oh my god i'm so embarrassed like me
alright okay everybody um thank you everyone I hope you guys
enjoyed I'll do an after party but uh because I put it at 7
30 I didn't think I'd be like streaming longer uh but like
I'm gonna delay it a little I'm gonna push the the after
party like maybe like 20 minutes more so I can like chill a
little bit but like a huge shout to the shad for doing
editing all of the editing all the uh the videos for it um I
definitely want my next karaoke I want to make it like
bigger and like more professional less less scuffed as this
time I want to do it less scuffed I'll definitely be much
more prepared I feel like I definitely could have worked on
this karaoke a lot more I feel like I definitely could have
worked on it a lot more um and gave myself more time but it
was definitely harder to balance everything that was going
on and I definitely could have practiced the songs a lot
more um um um but next time i'll make sure it's even all
right guys at what what what how many subscribers am i on
right now how many subscribers am i on at uh at 800k at 800k
subscribers will be my next karaoke and but that next
karaoke will be a bigger better more production value and I
would have practiced much more.
I promise all of you guys, I would practice a lot more.
For 800K.
Bigger production.
A lot more practice.
Less scuff.
And we'll have a better PC at 800K.
We get to 800K subscribers.
Like, huge production value.
More production value than the trumpet piano.
Bro, it's going to be bigger and better than the fucking
trumpet the piano i swear guys like that's when you know
it's more extreme
no way um but yes i am going to call i'm gonna uh end the
karaoke here uh i'll raid the um i'm gonna push the after
party waiting room to like 20 minutes uh 20 minutes to just
chill a little bit and reset myself but thank you everybody
for coming to my karaoke i'm sorry it's pretty scuffed and i
was crashing in the beginning i'm sorry for crashing a lot
in the beginning but it got better guys it got it stopped
crashing at least thank god but yes thank you i really did
enjoy myself i had a lot of fun with all the guys and i hope
you guys had a lot of fun watching um i really did have like
a lot of fun doing this karaoke for all you guys uh yes i'll
see you guys very very soon bye everybody bye